l'invité de ce journal c'est soeur
emmanuelle que vous connaissez bien pour
le travail qu'ils réalisent en egypte et
au soudan aux côtés des enfants laissés
pour compte on vous appelle la soeur des
chiffonniers soeur emmanuelle vous étiez
ici il ya tout juste un an
vous êtes ici pour trouver des fonds
pour votre oeuvre alors avant d'en
parler avant de parler de vos besoins de
vos problèmes
eh bien on va rappeler rapidement en
quoi consiste votre oeuvre avec un
reportage d'alain s'inquiétait à vos
côtés il y à quelque chose
le caire 14 millions d'habitants l'une
des villes les plus peuplées du monde
derrière ces immeubles derrière les
quartiers riches dans les ruelles les
faubourgs des pyramides de détritus ce
la municipalité commence tout juste à
organiser un service officiel de
ramassage des ordures depuis toujours
c'est la sphère des à baline ce sont des
chrétiens coptes
chaque matin il envoie les enfants
débarrasser la ville de ces rejets ils
sont quinze mille à vivre ici à l'écart
sur leurs montagnes qu en pour métier le
tri perpétuelle de toutes les matières
susceptibles d'être recyclés pour
salaires quelques piastres en échange de
tonnes de plastique de chiffon de papier
et de ferraille
milieu des parias de la décharge une
religieuse de 79 ans qui a tout quitté
pour vivre ici parmi eux son sacerdoce
depuis 16 ans elle est de toutes leurs
corvées l'égyptien et parmi les peuples
et plus intelligent si vous voulez aider
à mettre le pied dans l'étrier
il va courir sur la route plus vite que
les autres
lorsque nous les gaulois 907 revêtus de
peau de galles vivait dans les forêts
ils construisaient les pyramides c'est
un des peuples les plus intelligents du
monde et les plus sympathiques du monde
tant de richesses inexploitées pour en
tirer parti il ya les dons et la fois de
se re aiment à noël la création de
centres d'apprentissage mais il faut
aussi enrayer la mortalité infantile
il y a dix ans 4 enfants sur 10 moore
est dès leur première année
aujourd'hui ils sont 75% à survivre le
grand défi c'était aussi la
scolarisation de ces centaines d'enfants
de chiffonniers peu sont déjà presque
sauvés ils apprennent à lire et à écrire
et puis une autre initiative de soeur
emmanuelle convaincre des jeunes de
venir bénévolement ici pour participer à
cette énorme tâche
ils sont une quinzaine venus de divers
régions françaises à voir financer eux
mêmes leur voyage l'originalité
l'association c'est que on s'adresse à
des gens qui ne sont pas spécialistes à
dire que tous les gens qui sont pas ni
médecin ni infirmière ni etc peuvent
trouver là l'occasion de partir alors
qu'ils sont la plupart du temps refusé
par les autres organismes
le bidonville change de visage les tôles
ondulées qui certes encore d'habitation
disparaissent petit à petit et à leur
place naissent des maisons de briques et
de béton pierre par pierre
les oubliés du caire se construise un
avenir